hey how you doing today folks in this
video I'm going to continue my breakdown
of the plot leak and this is going to be
episode 4 so what I'll do is I'll read
the entire leaked episode then I'll go
back and breakdown each section of it
and talk about what's been confirmed
with photos and reports from websites
like watches on the wall then I'll talk
about what's likely or not likely to
happen so let's begin
it says aria arrives in Winterfell Dany
torches a few Westerosi Lords with her
dragons which include Sam Charlie's
father and brother Tyrion dissuades Dany
from attacking King's Landing directly
with her dragons for fear of killing
lots of civilians Jaime and Bronn and a
Lannister army are ambushed probably mid
season by Dany the Dothraki and her
dragons as they are marching back from
Highgarden the Lannister army is then
defeated and Jaime is almost killed by
the dragons only to be saved by bran
John realizes the only way to get
Westeros to work together to fight the
White Walkers is to get a live specimen
of a white to show to everyone so let's
go back to the beginning and start
breaking this stuff down it says Arya
arrives at Winterfell
I absolutely believe Arya will make it
back to Winterfell I think most of us
have been waiting for this day for quite
some time now because personally I got
bored with her story in Braavos to me it
felt like they were just treading water
with her there as they were setting up
other stories waiting for the right time
to be able to bring Arya back into the
mix but thankfully while she was there
she did learn how to defend herself and
become a faceless assassin so we last
saw Ahri at the twins when she killed
Walder Frey and his two sons so she
already has covered a lot of ground on
her way back home which is where she
told Jack and agar she was going in with
aurea's current location I think it
leaves her story with many possibilities
and opportunities to go in several
interesting directions so for those of
you that got bored with her story in
Braavos like I did I don't think there's
any reason to worry because from here on
out I think arias story arc can be one
of the most interesting ones if done
right and I've been looking forward to
seeing her back in Westeros that way her
story can start to intertwine with some
of my other favourite characters and
where she is currently at on a map
I think we are about to start seeing
just that and I think Aria is about to
run into several characters that are
still on her hit list making her story
one of the most anticipated ones to see
next season at least that's the way I
feel and you can see in my other video
that I made about aria some of these
reunions she will more than likely have
as she heads home so I definitely
believe this part of the leak is true
but this is one of the more obvious
things that guests so let's move on and
it says Danny torches a few Westerosi
Lords with their dragons which includes
Sam Charlie's father and brother now
this part of the leak is beginning to
appear like it's going to come true as
well originally I didn't believe it but
photos are coming out that show randyll
Tarly forces fighting side by side with
the Lannisters as they are defending
themselves from the Dothraki the
unsullied and then Danny's dragons and I
have yet to see any evidence of Daenerys
being there filming this scene more have
I seen any photos of them setting up in
in green screens on this battlefield to
film the dragon scenes but it is still
early in the filming process and
everything else that is building up for
this dragon attack is being confirmed
from the leaked photos so I have no
reason to dispute that the rest of this
won't happen but it looks like randyll
Tarly isn't going to have that much of
an effect on the current main story we
may not even have time to see him look
for salmon and sort hearts pain because
it appears like he's going to get wiped
out pretty quick but I wonder what this
means for Sam if his father and brother
do die then does that leave him the
rights to horn Hill now I don't really
see Sam living there but I don't see him
going back to Castle black either once
that wall comes down Castle black and
the Nights Watch are going to cease to
exist
which you can see in this other video I
made about the two so let me know what
you guys think about what the future of
Sam's story could be when his father and
brother die but let's move forward says
Tyrion dissuades Dany from attacking
King's Landing directly with dragons for
field for fear of killing lots of
civilians now there's been no evidence
of this yet but I can see why Tyrion
would advise this even though I think
Tyrion hates King's Landing and the
people living there
if Daenerys wants to continue to win
over the hearts and minds of the people
then she certainly can't destroy
everyone living where she wants to rule
and I don't think Danny wants to have
the same reputation her father had
either which is burning everyone in
sight and be remembered as the mad queen
deep down Tyrion has a good heart anyway
so I think it's obvious he wouldn't want
to see innocent people get cremated but
it also says Jaime and Bronn and a
Lannister army are ambushed midseason by
Danny the Dothraki and her dragons and
while Jamie Braun and their forces are
marching back from Highgarden that's
when the Lannister army gets defeated
and Jaime is almost killed by the
dragons but Bronn comes in and saves the
day
so this battle appears to be taking
place in the leaked photos but I have
yet to see Jaime or a Bronn in any kind
of trouble but one thing I'm wondering
is when Danny defeats the Lannister army
and torches the tarly's what is she
going to do with Jaime and Bronn
when Bronn saves Jaime is she just going
to allow them to get away or will she
then take both of them prisoner and use
them to negotiate with Cersei personally
I would love to see Tyrion talk Jaime
into joining Daenerys his cause and
support her but obviously Jaime has
still knee-deep in love with Cersei so
it may not be likely but it's just
something I would love to see I'd love
to see Jaime and Tyrion back together
but I wonder if Jaime and Bronn are able
to escape somehow though even though
their forces are defeated and they now
may be surrounded by Dothraki and the
unsullied is there a way for them to
escape
I think this scene could get pretty damn
crazy but let's go over the last part of
this episode where it says Jon realizes
the only way to get Westeros to work
together to fight the White Walkers is
to get a live specimen of a white to
show to everyone now there hasn't been
much evidence that they're filming this
scene yet
but in Northern Ireland they are
beginning to create a set with massive
green screens and a frozen pond with an
island in the center which is where Jon
and his team of inglorious bastards
could get attacked by the night's king
and they're reported 300 whites
as they're trying to get south of the
wall while they've been up there hunting
Nazis and I know this part of the lead
got the most hate it seems people
thought this was too unrealistic or too
dangerous or too stupid etc and those
people might be right but I think once
again if done right I think they could
pull this off and make this mission one
of the most intense and high-stakes
situations during season seven but one
thing about this group of characters
John's going to take with him
I think Gendry may actually be a
liability he may know how to make swords
but we know he has no idea how to swing
one which Ari had made very clear when
she made fun of him seasons ago
so taking Gendry on his mission is
pretty damn risky even if he has his
father's Warhammer if he has no idea how
to swing the thing taking him to try to
capture some weights is pretty dangerous
taking this small team is risky period I
think the chances of John coming across
one white by itself isn't very likely
they usually travel in packs or even in
the size of an army so I would hope if
John does do this he would take more
than just a few men so let me know what
you guys think about this leaked episode
what do you think about these different
parts of it does it still seem
unrealistic to you guys or some of you
starting to believe the photos and
reports like I am because by the look of
the photos to me it appears like most of
these things are definitely going to
take place next season but I want your
guys's thoughts and opinions on it so
comment below and I want to thank you
guys for taking your time out of your
day to listen to me
I appreciate your guys to support all
your positive comments I enjoy keeping
the conversation going after I post a
video so thank you guys for that and
I'll see you next time when I post
episode 5 thanks guys bye